here's how the world paid tribute the
Sydney Opera House a dazzling portrait
in Rio Christ the Redeemer lit up in New
York the Empire State Building but in
Paris the Glitters of the Eiffel Tower
were turned off the world a little
darker
president macron came to the British
Embassy to sign a book of condolence he
spoke of the queen as a close friend of
France
to you
she was your queen
to us
she was the queen
to us all
she would be with us forever
outside the Embassy Flowers were being
laid and among those we spoke to sadness
and respect
she's the only thing I
I knew in my lifetime she had her Duty
as I'm concern and in a democracy where
you have five five-year term it's
something that's really striking
the queen visited France 13 times more
than any other European country here in
France there really is a cocktail of
sympathy and affection and it is
replicated all over the world the truth
is that politicians may come and go but
the queen was something unique in global
public life she spent seven decades
representing Britain all over the world
America has lowered its Flags to
half-mast President Biden saying the
queen had defined an era and north of
the Border an emotional tribute from
Canada's leader Canada is in mourning
foreign
she was one of my favorite people in the
world
and I will miss her so
in death confirmation of the Queen's
extraordinary Fame messages from across
the whole world and the pope from China
the United Nations even from Vladimir
Putin
and in New Zealand that most profound of
honors a hacker to remember the queen
in an era of quick celebrity the world
has remembered a public figure who
endured for so very long Adam Parsons
Sky News Paris